shaking hands with the veterans
a salute from his defence minister
before taking to the podium to honor
russia's servicemen to stress russian
exceptionalism and to deliver another
rebuke to the west who he says forced
him to move into ukraine
[Music]
as ever guarding the scene as the tanks
rolled through red square the
commander-in-chief looking on a blanket
on his lap and his face hard to read as
his troops yelled their support
in the absence of any actual victory on
the battleground this was really all
that vladimir putin could do claim the
moral high ground that this is all about
defending the motherland while showing
off his nuclear arsenal while he's at it
no flyover this year because of the rain
but the spectators still loved it the
message that russia here is blameless
hitting home
foreign vladimir putin has elevated the
soviet victory in world war ii to almost
cult status during his 22 years in power
the hard-fought but eventual victory the
nazi threat motifs of his rhetoric now
around ukraine harking back to the
sacrifice of his soviet forebears
and in poland where russia's ambassador
tried to lay a wreath in memory
protesters threw red paint and chanted
fascist at him
a site which won't go down well back
home
russians in their millions march each
year to commemorate their fathers and
grandfathers vladimir putin leading the
way with a portrait of his father
huge crowds to honor the 27 million who
fought and died in what's known here as
the great patriotic war
gardener
um
[Applause]
stay a few years in russia and you'll
recognize the patriotic songs but we
were surprised to hear this one sung in
ukrainian by a man whose mother lives
outside kharkiv who prefer relations to
be as they were in soviet times
[Music]
his mother just wants to plant potatoes
he says keep ducks to eat them in winter
she just wants peace
but that might be a long time coming and
at what cost this time round
[Music]
and how will history judge the russian
people a few decades from now